foreign
s us up next in Austin Texas Andrew
welcome to the show
thanks guys how are you all doing we're
doing great what's going on with you
uh not much man just looking for a
little bit of advice here um so I've
been listening to the show for a little
bit and I'm just trying to figure out
the best moves next like I've saved up
started some of the baby steps saved up
a thousand bucks you know and I'm really
just trying to get debt free at this
point I have a little bit of credit card
debt about 6 500 bucks and then around
seven thousand nine hundred ninety
dollars in student loan debt
um and I've got a uh a stock from a
previous company that you know company
that I worked for they had a stock
purchase program you get a discount
they'd buy the stock for you essentially
and it's done well for itself and I've
got about twelve thousand dollars in
that so I was thinking about selling
that stock and then using that money to
pay off the majority of my debt I'm just
trying to decide if that's the best idea
or if I sh if I should still hold the
stock
um but if I do pull the starter if I do
sell it should I put it towards my
credit card that has interest on it
right now and then the remainder towards
my student loan debt or vice versa so
that's kind of just my where my thought
process is right now I just can't decide
what the best move is I love it well
welcome to the club of weirdos who do
money differently and one of those
things is cashing out those stocks now
beware you want to work with the tax Pro
there's going to be a tax implication
here on the gains and so make sure you
have that set aside to pay Uncle Sam
when that time comes due but yes use the
rest of that towards your smallest
balance so if that's your credit card
regardless of interest rate we are
attacking the smallest debt first so
you're going to knock out the credit
card tomorrow and then most of the
student loans going to get knocked out
too do you have money saved in the bank
as well
uh yeah I've got a let's see well I've
got about
two or three thousand just saved in the
bank and then I've got uh around thirty
six thousand and a 401k and about 8 000
in a Roth IRA okay so I haven't done
terrible saving but I'm just trying to
knock out Cadet so I can save more yeah
well definitely do not touch any
retirement accounts don't pull any money
out of that but these stocks sound like
they're outside of retirement correct
correct yeah they were just uh it was
just an offering from the company and an
additional benefit essentially that was
like you know I can save up for this
it'll be money pulled out of my paycheck
that I won't see I won't I won't miss it
and then hopefully it'll work out and
this stock has gone from at certain
times it was bought at around 120 a
share and now it's around 350 a share
I'm cashing out while the game
because three weeks from now you're
gonna say I'm gonna hold it just to see
what happens and then for some reason it
tanks and all of a sudden your debt free
date just got pushed out so we tell
anyone if you've got volatile things
like crypto single stocks and you've got
debt just cash it out man you can't beat
the feeling of debt freedom and you're
going to get there so fast you're almost
there if you cash everything out of the
bank except for that thousand for your
starter emergency fund cash out the
stocks throw all of that on it you're
gonna be like pennies away from debt
freedom
yeah yeah and that's that's kind of
where my head was at and I just was like
yeah I just didn't know the best way to
to go about it um but yeah real close
and just want to be done with with the
credit card and student loan debt be
done never look back and cut up those
cars close the accounts you will not
miss it man I'm telling you right now